mark Pellegrino is an actor who's been
in such films as The Big Lebowski and
national treasure and he's been in
roughly a billion TV shows like
Supernatural Quantico Dexter lost in the
closer he's also the co-founder of the
American capitalist society mark welcome
to the show thanks for having me
did I did I pick the right shows there
you actually did yeah thank you you feel
good about that line yeah you've got a
long IMDB and yet we're not gonna talk
about acting right yeah I'm more than
all right with the thing yeah
actors talking about acting it's that's
what we get from actors got to be the
most boring boring subject matter on the
planet yeah so I'm glad we're avoiding
it all right well we're gonna go deep
into into politics and capitalism and
free speech a lot of stuff that I really
love so let's start with that
so as an actor I find that many actors
are sort of trained not to really say
what they think really share their
feelings about things especially when it
comes to politics and and opinions and
yet you're involved with the American
capitalist party yes ilysm doesn't seem
like the cool thing these days we're
into socialism yes yeah how'd you get
mixed up in cata yeah I don't know that
that must have just been a twist of fate
because I was educated in these
state-run schools to believe that
capitalism was probably the worst thing
to hit civilization since the plague and
but I grew out of that simply by
observing you know by by observing the
the prosperity that it brought so and I
see I see in in the political world
around us a market now for a free market
ideas because what I see in the
political spectrum is basically one
party with with with with two sorts of
expressions you know they both agree on
the premise of government and they
disagree on degrees yeah of that premise
but they they both agree yeah and what's
interesting about that is
I don't know that there's ever been a
better example of that than we have
right now we're assuming that it's
Clinton on the Democratic side and we
know it's gonna be Trump they're both
basically centrist short Trump says a
lot of crazy things and a lot of people
don't like things about Hillary but
they're not that different right they've
been to weddings together they've done a
lot of money things together so that
proves it more than anything else that
these parties are pretty much in bed
together and they're in bed together I
think I think the premise that they both
agree on is that it's appropriate to use
state aggression to achieve a good they
disagree on what that good is and on how
much state aggression should be applied
and in what areas but they but they
agreed that aggression is a good thing
right so okay so if you don't want the
state to be growing basically that's one
of the premises we'll talk about some of
the principles in the party then this is
a really nightmarish election right now
because this whole thing even Trump on
the Republican side for someone that
wants small government this is not a
small government Republican I don't know
there aren't many left I suppose
and certainly Bernie and and Hillary are
not small government people sack that's
kind of depressing for someone that
wants the government out of your life
right yeah I mean I don't I don't even
equate small government with good
government I equate a government that
respects individual rights and and holds
properties and viable as a good as a
good government because a small
government can be just as authoritarian
as a large government it's if its
premises are that aggression is
appropriate mm-hmm
so when did you have your sort of
political awakening you said you went to
state schools where they tell you
capitalism was bad
yet it was capitalism that was funding
these state schools because this was in
America is it yes yeah yeah so when when
did your awakening sort of happen I
think I think in my mid-20s when a
friend of mine who was in the theater
company that I belonged to introduce me
to the writings of iron Rand and at the
time I would consider myself a I would
consider myself a leftist I was the
registered Democrat and fully on the
side of statism without quite
understanding what that meant and her
writings threw me into a bit of a moral
and philosophical tailspin for
for years and it took about a decade for
me to resolve all the issues that she
that she kind of threw in my face and
made me think about yeah what do you
make of when you just say I ran I I had
your own Brooke who's the president of
the Iran yes foundation on just a couple
weeks ago a friend of mine and and a
great guy and I thoroughly enjoyed our
back-and-forth and I have to say that
probably 90% of the reaction we got to
it was positive but the 10% that well
even people that disagreed with the
specifics of how the government should
work or capitalism or you know free will
whatever it was it was all positive and
on point but the the 10% that disagreed
it wasn't there wasn't a lot based in
fact it was just screaming like horrible
you know all these awful words and all
that kind of stuff why do you think that
the philosophy of capitalism or
objectivism if we go that you know
tightly with it brings out such emotion
in people I think because it's based on
the the ethics of rational self-interest
and most people have a sort of spectrum
in their minds when they're thinking of
values and ethics and the spectrum is
you're either and and this and the
spectrum is informed by altruism
basically so that's that's the umbrella
under which everyone sees and defines
the good and to the degree that you are
selfish and and acting for your own
interests is the degree that you're
parting from the concept of altruism
which is a sacrificial ethics which says
the other should be the beneficiary of
values not you right rational
self-interest is that you should be the
beneficiary of the values that you that
you go for so okay so there's there's so
much there because that's where people
start going crazy it seems obvious to me
that if you were to do what is good for
you that doesn't mean you're going to
screw everyone else over if you were
gonna do what's good for you and in your
house well then what you do what's good
in your house is probably good for your
community it's probably good for the
wider community yes you could do all
kinds of awful things at the expense of
people but but I think this is the
disconnect people don't understand that
by doing good for yourself in a way
you're actually doing good for many
other people right is that sort of the
I think I think even though that isn't
the primary focus that is the
consequence for sure I think I think
amongst rational people there is no
conflict of interest and there is no
clash of rights in a status kind of
world that we live in then a person
going for what they want using state
aggression will will clearly do it by
gaining at the expense of somebody else
yeah
and that's sort of the the alternatives
that the the altruistic mindset gives us
you're either sacrificing yourself to
somebody else or sacrificing somebody
else to yourself and rights sort of by
nature are meant to clash yeah and I
don't think that's true in a rational
world right so we live in this time
where everyone's virtue signaling all
the time and we know what's going on on
college campuses where they're playing
this oppression Olympics thing so in a
way this is really the this is either
the antidote or at least the Codel
reverse of all of that right agreed as
opposed to just pretending that you're
for all the you're for all these groups
and then what gets lost in these groups
is the individuals and it's really about
the individual it is about the
individual it all comes down to the
individual the individual is the one who
thinks individuals one who pursues
values groups don't society doesn't
that's society and these groups are just
composed of individuals pursuing their
own ends and hopefully they're rational
and so they don't come at the expense of
somebody else yeah all right so you
started or co-founded the American
capitalist party damn what made you say
alright I'm gonna put my name out there
and I'm gonna go for something that's
that's bigger than me and and try to
change things for the better well just
I'm just not not seeing the alternatives
out there you know and and and seeing
that the parties agreed on an ethical
premise and and and so that people we're
not really seeing that there there's an
other side another argument that needs
to be brought to the fore and and for me
the fundamental question is is as I said
do you want state aggression as a means
of achieving the good or do you think
individuals pursuing their own happiness
as immoral when you say state aggression
I think some people probably think you
mean you're just you're talking about
war
or by coercion through a gun but it's
not necessarily just that right it's
initiated force against against an
individual who's committed no crime so
it it it covers the spectrum of from
from war unjust Wars all the way to the
regulatory state which in my mind is is
an act of aggression against producers
to redistribute capital in the name of
justice and so I feel like the actual
alternatives the the real alternatives
that exist in the political spectrum is
statism or Liberty and and and if you
believe that the state is an appropriate
means to achieve the good then you are
to that degree of status and if you
believe that individuals pursuing their
own happiness is a moral ideal and in no
way creates conflict then you go for
something like capitalism yeah isn't the
sad part of this that so I'm obviously
on board most of this and I want to get
into classical liberalism in a minute ok
but just as you were saying that I was
thinking you know when when we had the
primaries it's like we had those what I
think it started at 17 Republicans yeah
the only guy who touched on anything
that you just said at all was Rand Paul
who dropped out after lose either the
straw poll or the first primary I mean
that really tells you how sad our
politics are right it's distressing it
is distressing but and I think that's a
result of a couple of things
look this Trump phenomenon is is sort of
an expression of something healthy on
the one hand in that people are upset
mm-hmm they they understand that
political the PC movement is a sort of
tyranny and authoritarianism and and
irrational and they're tired of being
under its thumb and they they see how it
leads this kind of a kind of a systemic
dishonesty and and they're tired of
political elitism and they want their
their you know their notions to be
reflected in government they don't want
to be ignored and I think I think those
are very very powerful and and and true
assessments of the
I'm out there the issue though with
Trump I never thought he'd get this far
- I thought the American people would be
mad that expressed that anger but at
some point latch onto a principal and
somebody like a Rand Paul or even a
cruise you know who's sort of a
constitutional conservative would would
rise to the top your reaction right
there when you said Cruz that's sort of
how everybody felt about Cruz even the
people that liked him on the
constitutional stuff I think everybody
was kind of like just not this guy could
there be to somebody else no it's that
social agenda of conservatism that they
that they have to play to during every
election that sort of bugs me I'm sorry
it's the that's their version of the
appropriateness of using force against
people right wait let's just unpack that
a little bit so basically they would be
for all the things that you've talked
about they're for capitalism and suppose
in smaller government and states rights
and things like that and yet there's
this social component that I think you
would be completely against right so
when they're when they're getting the
government involved in who you marry and
what you smoke in your bedroom and
things of that nature that actually is
completely against what their ideology
is but they've coupled that somehow with
religion which a libertarian or a
classic liberal or a true capitalist I
suppose would be completely sure and I
don't and I don't even think they're
true representatives of capitalism as
well they're they're just as they've
been just as much a party to the fall of
the United States and to statism as the
political left has been and have never
really been very strong moral advocates
of capitalism anybody any pundit I've
heard on the right at best can say
there's no shame in the profit motive
but I've never heard them just say it's
positively good right if business works
yes actually good because you can hire
people and people can buy things and
things that nature alright so I know a
certain amount of people watching we're
only ten minutes and so are gonna say
this guy's a conservative he's a
everything he said is a conservative
that's funny I never emailed my guests
with questions in advance or anything
beforehand I did say to you something
about just a quick one line or sending
something about it's nice to have an
actor with some conservative leanings or
something because actors don't talk
about this stuff and you immediately
wrote back and said well I'm not a
conservative I'm a
SiC liberal yes now this is a phrase
that I've been talking a lot about
nobody really understands what it is
it's very close to libertarianism but
why don't you give me your definition of
what a classic liberal I will link
people to thank God and I think a
classic liberal is one that believes
that government is a monopoly of force
and that force has only one Morrow
expression in society and and that is in
a retaliatory expression so that like a
classical liberal I think believes that
you should ban the initiation of force
from all interpersonal relationships and
that that is the way that that
individual rights are preserved and the
inviolability of property is preserved
so that's my take on yeah I don't know
yeah well close I I would add I read a
great quote by Bertrand Russell we're
saying that that the classic liberal
also will change their opinions as
evidence changes not necessarily that
you're changing your moral compass but
you're willing to change as you learn
new information and we live in a time
where people just don't do that people
are afraid to change their opinions
because they're called flip-floppers or
they just get so stuck in something that
they only you know it's like on Twitter
if you only follow people that reinforce
your opinion well then then you never
chain you're in the echo chamber exactly
well I think I think it needs to be a
distinction that's made between
principle and dogma you know and
principles sort of hold for all time
they're like laws of nature the rest are
and and I yes I think liberal a liberal
especially classic liberal is is
intellectually flexible for sure but
that just speaks to the fact that
liberals are rational and and they hold
reason as a primary as opposed to any
other means of knowledge but that but
but let's not let's not push push away
the concept of principled and you know
and and believe that well if that's
easily divorce' below you know because I
think those those hold for all
time and the pragmatists that we see
today in politics who shift in
constantly at Donald Trump is a perfect
example right unprincipled pragmatist
that's sort of the opposite as an anti
intellectual kind of flexibility so I
think we want that you know that love of
reality and love of reason and that
understanding that a principle is is a
is an accumulation of fact it's it's you
know it's it's a short of a minute
mental shorthand for a lot of
information and that it holds true for
all time
yeah so that's really the the catch-22
with Trump right like we've all been
waiting desperately for someone to break
through the nonsense and one to not only
be on prompter someone to actually speak
like we speak someone to not be afraid
to share every opinion even if it's
going to upset some people and yet you
just hit on it the the sort of
underpinnings of what he's saying really
make no sense he's saying everything and
yet I've had a mildly innopolis right on
who's a big Trump supporter said that
this election just simply isn't about
policy it's just about this social it's
about that it's just about this social
component people are so sick of that
that that's purely all they're voting on
but that that's a kind of scary place to
be interested a place to be it is a
scary place to be and but understandable
as I said political correctness has is
it is a tyranny and we are seeing it in
the colleges today know how language is
being taken over by this by this
movement and and people just don't want
that anymore yeah I wish there were an
intellectual alternative to a guy like
Trump to be honest I just wish them yeah
I wish but we'll have to continue to
wish at least for now but I'm a firm
believer that because of all this by
2020 I think we're probably gonna have a
viable third party so you started this
party yeah so how is this different how
is the American capitalist party
different than the libertarian party
because I was reading the platform in
the principals and all that did you take
what did you like it I did like it a lot
I mean it's yeah I mean it's exactly the
stuff that I've I've been talking about
and without crit you know you're not
staking out crazy positions these all
seem very it seemed based in the reason
and logic that I try to apply anything
so I like that
but how is that different than the
Libertarian Party while speaking of
reason and logic
I think libertarianism in the end is
about win worship sort of the thing
that's animating the Trump phenomenon
libertarianism as far as I can see the
most consistent practitioners of
libertarianism don't think that
government has an appropriate place in
society at all they consider a coercive
monopoly that will always be a course of
monopoly irrespective of whether or not
it's constrained by a contract like a
constitution and so they just want to
eliminate it entirely and put force on
the marketplace if the way other you
know goods and services are traded and
capitalism understands the capitalist
party understands that to be a very bad
idea right it forces into marketable
commodity and that it needs to be
deposited in an organization that that
is governed by objective laws and whose
sole purpose is to protect the
individual from criminals and from the
initiation of force yeah so when people
give capitalism when they basically are
like it's just not working and look
what's happening in America or all the
all the Bernie rallies and he talks
about the 1% and even though it's really
the point one percent I think that he's
really talking about cuz they talk about
the 1% it sounds like if you make around
400 grand you're in the 1% at 400 you're
not pulling the strings of of
politicians you're living a nice life
sure but but so the real problem that
people having with capitalism now I
think is the crony capitalism that we
have right just the way that bad actors
have used the capitalist system do you
think that's fair to say well I mean
yeah and I wouldn't call it crony
capitalism I think I think cronyism is a
form of statism it's fascism and and and
linking it with capitalism sort of puts
capitalism in us in a spectrum that it
doesn't deserve to be put in I mean what
we have now and have had for over a
century is a mixed economy where there
is elements of freedom and elements of
controls
and the elements of freedom of course
lead to the prosperity that we like and
the elements of control dislocate the
market from the the measuring tools that
it needs in order to you know give us
what we want it dislocates the market
from the price prices and from the
profit and and from the things that
enable you know the resource isn't
capital to be allocated properly and
causes these kinds of massive economic
problems that we've had over the last
century or so since the coming of the
Federal Reserve so I I don't I don't
like linking businessmen who have
political pull with free-market people
who produce a value that other people
want right so you see that more as a
political problem than a problem of
capitalism itself right but that shows
you how these this stuff is also
intertwined right because if you make a
lot of money then you have access to
politicians who can then change laws to
then you rig the system so we're in like
a real a real mess here right well so
how do we at this point understanding
that I mean how do we unpin some of that
without burning the system down because
that's what it to me right now it seems
to me that the Bernie people and the
Trump people that they have one thing in
common which is let's burn down and I
would say the system as screwy as it is
and unfair as it is and it needs to get
better but burning it down I don't think
is is the way to go well I think
eventually that is the solution I think
there is no compromise between statism
and liberty it's one or the other and
you see over the last 120 some odd years
how the one is slowly taking over the
other because because of the fact that
the the political right who's supposed
to stand for the free-market hasn't
because they can't because they've been
compromised in the entire time yeah with
statism so in the end the system does
have to go in favor of either one that
protects individual rights or one that
fully endorses the states rights to to
direct the life of the individual so but
but I think it has to be dismantled not
in one
fell swoop there's too much dependence
on right right well that's what I mean
that when you just they like the idea of
burning it down but I just think come
out on the other side we don't know what
will happen so you think there's a way
of sort of incrementally getting rid of
some of this stuff some of this
regulation and it incrementally came
upon us I think that's the way you have
to ease our way out of it but I but I
think it's it's up to the intelligentsia
and the artistic community to embrace
the different values that in order to
make this palatable to the American
people I mean if you continue thinking
that altruism
is is the appropriate moral code then
statism is simply going to be the
political extension of that and if you
believe that you have a right to your
own life and the pursuit of your
happiness is a moral good then then you
know a different system is is what you
would you would be for and that's going
to take some time to saturate the
culture notions yeah we got a lot of
work in front of them you do this is the
answer so you believe that those those
moral concepts that those really come
from man right there is in a this has
nothing to do with religion or with I
don't know what your personal feelings
on religion atheist but okay you're an
atheist so so that's also interesting
because I've talked you know I talk a
lot about the political side and I talk
a lot about atheism there there's some
connection there what is that connection
I mean I didn't know if you were gonna
tell me you're Christian or you're a
believer or whatever I think it's gonna
be irrelevant I think it's been a
disastrous thing that capitalism has
been linked with judeo-christian values
and capitalism has been linked and and
the concept of rights have been linked
to an unprovable and knowable God I mean
to me the concept of right is just means
a freedom of action and it's observable
it's an you can see in reality why a
human being needs to be free from force
okay right you can't think with a gun
pointed to your head and you can't act
in your own interests or pursue values
or create values with a gun pointed to
your head hmm so the concept look rights
wouldn't matter if you were on a desert
island property wouldn't matter if you
were on a desert island by yourself it's
it's it's a social moral conscious
in it and it comes from our nature it
it's it's founded in and and it comes
from our nature as rational beings and I
think linking it to God makes it
unjustifiable yeah in the in the eyes of
any rational human being out there right
and that's where they've also used
government they've been able to link it
to God and then made government bigger
so if you're on the right like I give so
much crap to my friends on the Left who
are controlling language doing doing all
the things that you just laid out right
now so I'm trying to to bring the left
back a little Center I think but but
it's the people on the right who have
used God in this equation that have
expanded government because as we said
before they are the ones that want to
control who you marry and what you smoke
and all that and that is the reverse of
everything else they're supposed to
believe in agreed and and but the left
is the same thing I remember reading a
quote from Theodore Roosevelt who
started this disaster of progressivism
that he cared about people not property
and I've had discussions with people on
the Left who simply do not understand
that property in life the pursuit of
your happiness your body and property
are intimately intertwined and you can't
have one without the other so that's why
the left I think
thinks it's okay to to take and
redistribute what you've earned to other
people in the name of the good because
your property is something communal it's
it goes for something greater than you I
on the other hand as you're right I also
think a lot of it's just nonsense I
think a lot of them don't practice what
they preach they live for themselves
they try to maximize their own profits I
think a lot of them that own businesses
would be happy not to have unions or do
every other which way to not give their
employees $15 an hour
sure I mean I see this with people I
know and how they treat people that
they're you know that are huge lefties
that don't really live up to any of
these principles so that's that virtue
signaling thing like I'm so good I'm so
good look how good I am but but it's
unlivable it's not it's not really a
moral premise that can sustain itself or
sustain life you know and I don't and I
don't think it's a
at moral code to have to have a standard
of value that's outside your ability to
achieve and and to define the good in
such a way that it's impossible to
achieve it or impossible to have a good
life while achieving it or impossible to
have any life while achieving it right
so how do we get the younger people on
board this because that's the the part
we've touched on it slightly I mean the
college stuff right now we know is
completely out of control every day you
know I mean we see protests you can
protest but if you're silencing people
now we have a free speech problem and I
keep saying I'm not that concerned at
the moment that the government is coming
for my free speech but I am concerned
that our our social contract of letting
each other speak that well that's being
shredded right now so what do we do in
terms of getting some young people on
board this well I think I think these
ideas have to start entering the culture
you know and have to start finding some
acceptance in the universities
themselves and that's going to take a
couple of generations I think in the
meantime I think political movements can
sort of be the initiator to cultural
movements you know I think I think
progressivism even though is an
intellectual movement it was sort of
foisted on the American people first I
don't think they they necessarily were
behind the idea that the stage it should
control every aspect of your life you
know in the night early 1900s sort of at
the height of the capitalist movement
and that so for me progressivism came as
as a political movement that sort of
saturated the culture and and I'm hoping
that bringing these capitalist ideas to
the fore and presenting them in a way
that any rational human being could look
at them and say what problem do I have
with this this makes complete sense it's
a way of initiating some cultural change
right so that really though is the is
the real damage that these trigger
warnings and safe spaces and all that
does right that now these kids are just
simply they won't even get to hear what
you've just laid out or what some other
person might laid out because they could
be a
by it or it somehow seems racist because
you're not putting everyone on this
chart of oppression Olympics so we have
to crack that and I don't know that we
have generations to do it well I think
also redefining some political terms
will help that as well liberalism had a
long tradition of intellectual
intellectual strength yeah and and it
was it was taken over you know and it's
changed now and I think taking back that
that label so that the political left
isn't able to progress further as a
party that's connected to intellectual
values but you know simply disconnect
them from the concept of liberal and and
return liberalism to its you know
rightful place which is anyone who
believes that the individual has a right
to their own life and who adheres to
reason and reality can be a political
liberal and and and just let the left
and the right kind of coalesce and find
their own little yeah and most people
are there I really believe that most
people I was watching Gary Johnson I
think this weekend on CNN and was saying
that he thinks around 40% of the
American electorate if they really
understood this stuff they'd realize
that they pretty much are for smaller
government as a rule that they are for
social liberalism and letting people
live the way they want but we get so
caught up in the craziness and then you
throw in a trump into this situation and
we just never have the intellectual
discussion about it so that's sort of
where where we fall right like we've got
a we've got to keep pushing well I mean
I I don't know if politics has always
been this way I feel like back in the
day that there was some conceptual
component to it now it's concrete bound
emotion driven and you can't really get
beyond bromides and sound bites you know
that and this is the one arena where
there really should be deep discussion
because we're talking about social
ethics those are concepts that are just
not so easily flushed down yeah we don't
have any of it I mean really if you
think about all I think about all the
debates on both sides I think there were
a couple debates where on the Democratic
side they really had some interesting
substantive stuff when they were talking
about guns for example I think there
were they had some differences Bernie
explained why yeah he's been more
relaxed on guns than Hillary in a rural
state but pretty much these debates and
almost everything we see in the media is
anti-intellectual right yeah I mean sure
when you turn on cable news do you ever
feel smarter after that that's I mean I
watch at this point I really only watch
what I'm doing cardio and I just put it
on I take my earbuds in and out cuz I
can't even watch ya for that long but
but I always feel Dumber I always feel I
haven't learned anything and that's so a
lot of this is just media stuff too
yeah and that's visual media too and
visual media is more superficial Inuk
and it goes for the bells and whistles
and and you know the the headline
grabbers and the thing that will
immediately emotionally draw you in as
opposed to the more substantive
conceptual stuff that I think you and I
want to see right when we're watching so
part of this is just the nature of how
we get news right we're so used to
Twitter we're so used to vine and
snapchat everything is so short but to
get people if if we were to have a real
debate you know every time there's a
debate I say these aren't debates a
debate is where you challenge someone's
ideas directly these are precision
questions that most likely they've been
tipped off to war hand and that's that's
really infuriating to watch sure
everybody's canned everybody has their
they're rehearsed responses nobody's
know to be speaking off-the-cuff or at
least off-the-cuff intelligent you know
and so we have this sort of canned
universe that we're watching unfold
before eyes where do you think
capitalism is working better than it's
working right here is there a country
that you look at and you go or a system
somewhere or even a microcosm of it in
America somewhere that you go this this
is how it's supposed to work and that's
what we can use as a little bit of a
path to get there well ironically I
don't think there is any country on the
face of the earth that embraces
capitalism fully but even more
ironically the countries of Bernie
Sanders talk
about our more free than America they
have more capitalist elements to them
than America and you know they certainly
confiscate more of their citizens wealth
and redistribute it but there are a lot
of ways in which you can say that those
countries are not socialist paradises
but mixed economy with more elements of
freedom than even the United States wait
so what's that what's the freer part so
when he's talking about somebody's
really more like the Scandinavian
countries I guess where they're they
have incredibly high tax card behind tax
but easier to start businesses you know
and in a much less certification the
licensure stuff stuff like that that
makes you know that makes capitalism
rather difficult here or the government
creates obstacles here to to making new
businesses are not present there and and
so it's not really an accurate thing for
him to point that out the point those
two those countries of socialist mecca's
since since they're just embracing free
markets and and a couple of them like
Sweden you know had a free-market
revolution in the in the 19th century
that that carried on into the into the
1960s when the Socialists took over so
capitalism is such a powerful thing that
it can be dead for decades and decades
and decades in a country and even
ideologically dead and yet still the
productivity that was generated from
that from that explosion of free markets
creates wealth still even though it's
sort of an intellectual dead letter over
there right so where does the the pure
capitalists or where does the American
capitalist party where would you guys
fall out on taxes because um I guess
ultimately because I do believe in
equality because I believe in real
equality I'm pretty much for a flat tax
but I would also say that you could have
some level of progressive tax that would
make sense so that if somebody I'm not
talking about if you make a million
dollars you should be taxed more
necessarily but at some level maybe over
20 million we can figure out little
percentages you know a quarter you I
think there's some fairness in there and
I know that probably a lot a lot of
libertarians would say no that's not
fair at all right I could do some of
that do you follow that line I think
you know what's your general feeling on
taxes well first of all III think that
the graduated tax is is not really just
for the most part a person who is
earning that kind of money has also
created exponentially more wealth than
they're actually taking home so but a
lot of people say they're just hiding
that money they're hiding it but you
would argue that they're they buy in a
big house and I have to have a gardener
and a well I would say that a Bill Gates
takes home 50 billion dollars he's
created two trillion two trillion
dollars of wealth so the fairness of
taxing him you know more because he has
50 billion dollars sort of loses its its
moral luster when you consider that he's
created exponentially more wealth it
benefits everybody I think I wasn't
totally sold on what I think there's a
there's an argument to add there and I
haven't quite well I just think I think
people forget that a person has that
kind of wealth because they've created
exponentially more wealth so they so
they forget that they have a
misperception that you know all these
people are just sitting there they're
shuffling papers around or they're
they're making transactions that are
really not benefiting Evan to anybody so
it's just money accumulating on money
and nobody benefits from that which is
it's sort of impossible I think in in
the way the economy works today even if
you just set your money in a in a
savings account somewhere I mean it's
it's going to be benefiting other people
in in innumerable ways but as far as
taxation goes i III support a flat tax
as a sort of intermediary stage to what
I think is ideal and and what I think
has ideal it is a completely voluntary
tax system where where you pay a very
very very small amount of your income to
support the legitimate functions of
government so if you think about it you
know if the government now functions it
what is it what does it function what is
it function at every year now it's a lot
really huge but the actual actual proper
functioning of a night watchman type
government that just protects your
rights is really really really
infinitesimally small in comparison so
it would be a very very very small
fractional amount of your in
in comparison to what we have to give
today but did you say voluntary yea
Balter so so most people are gonna hear
that what is he talking about who's
gonna volunteer to give the government
money well if you're actually well right
now we have an adversarial system that
where people sense the injustice of
having the fruits of your labor stolen
from you and your values verted and your
dream subvert it for the sake of other
people even if they don't want a minute
they they sense that that's sort of an
unjust thing but if if you're paying the
police and the courts and the army to
protect you from bad guys it's something
that I think most people can wrap their
their heads around and so what would
what would be those core things so it's
police it's firemen it's roads no no I
don't even know the road really well
this goes to firemen we've got a little
Atlas Shrugged here right well I mean
look of course there was a time when you
know the people were responsible for
that themselves that are when the burden
fell to the states you know in a more
federalist system but I definitely think
that the the civil civilized society
delegates the use of force to a to a
body that is governed by objective law
and so and so that is the purpose of
government is simply to protect you from
bad guys from fraud and force and
invasions and and stuff like that and
and the infrastructure of the country is
more or less the responsibility of you
and I and and I think it is in our
interest to to build these things it's
or to have somebody build them and to
pay them for that right so that goes to
where I started which is that people
think that being self-interested is
selfish but usually by being
self-interested you actually are
interested in the greater good because
you understand that that helps you right
I mean isn't isn't that the the piece
that right you're gonna go I'm
self-interested but I want roads so I'm
going to help roads be made well you
know I think yeah I mean when I hear
greater good it's a little scary to me
because because pretty much every
authoritarian government on the planet
that's murdered millions upon millions
done it in the name
the greater good and you have to reduce
that greater good to the individual and
there is no greater good than the
individual and certainly a person
pursuing their own values and exchanging
with somebody else has to have a
reputation if they want to continue to
exchange with another person which means
they have to produce and and and be a
benevolent reputable member of their
their community yeah I think there's no
more benevolent community than one that
says I don't expect the unearned and
hopefully you don't as well we can
exchange as equals with each other we
can trade to mutual benefit but that's
how that's and that that is that's how
we maintain a non violent non aggressive
society that's how we avoid conflict
with each other I respect you as an
individual and your property your life
as inviolable as mine so I can't like I
would by virtue of that ethics alone you
know not treat you in a manner that
would hurt you or violate your cause you
pain so I wasn't thinking of asking you
this but as we've come from that this is
this comes from man this this moral code
comes from your mind so then we're in
this system something like abortion now
you're protecting the individual this is
all then about the individual so what is
in the womb that child is an individual
and yet you want the government out so
how do you have no regulation when it
comes to abortion because you want to
protect the individual and yet you want
no regulator there's some level of fight
here I get a lot of crap from my point
of view on abortion oh well I'm glad
there's gonna be a lot of people that
hate me for this and I've had some
Twitter wars with people over it look to
me rights are a social moral concept
like I said before if you're on a desert
island you know there's you don't you
don't have to worry about the concept of
right because the only person who can
stop you from acting or thinking is
another person right so you do you got
to do right and so that that's where
rights are applicable so to me
makaan Sept of abortion the woman's as a
already existing value already pursuing
life her choice is pretty much all that
matters and until the child is born when
it's now in a social environment when
when it's needs have to be met amongst
people then it has right so to say that
to say that rights begin at birth is a
controversial thing for people because
you know they they change the equation
to life when does life begin right lots
of lots of things have life and not
rights and and and so as far as I'm
concerned it's applicable to a separate
individual and being in a social context
right I guess this is one of the ones
where people you know everyone wants a
purity test that you see this on with
every political partner now it's like
the Republicans want a purity test which
is why they'll talk about these Rhinos
Republicans in name only and you see the
Democrats doing this fighting to be
who's the most progressive because
that's the only way you can be a
Democrat it's just silly
and then in something like this I mean I
would I would say that at at seven
months certainly that that that fetus is
life so I get what you're saying you're
you're human a human being it is an
individual at that point yeah it can't
exist without someone helping it and
feeding it and everything else but at
seven months this is this is a livable
but it's still breathing through the
mother it's still eating but it but if
you were to take it out at that moment
yeah seven months most likely this this
can live these are arguably I mean these
are these are the so these are the brain
areas that are very very interesting I
don't think that one should ban the the
procedure at that late stage even though
I think nature sort of compels you not
to have an abortion procedure of that
stage of things it makes it an extremely
difficult and risky for the mother so
Nature has the final sort of word on
that but I think bands are very risky
and at the same time I think that
forcing people who find abortion morally
abhorrent to subsidize abortion or birth
control or or any other process that
they find morally repugnant
is morally repugnant itself so I think
pulling federal funding from places like
that is the beginning believe it or not
I hate to align myself folks that I
disagree with on so many other levels
but I think it's the beginning of a a
stance on the protection of individual
rights rights oh that's funny so in this
case you're aligning yourself with
people that you probably have no
agreement with in so many cases like
basically the Christian conservatives
right but that shows you how muddled our
politics are right that we don't really
have clean lines anymore as to what
anyone thinks so you can be just because
you're against government control of all
this subtly you're aligning yourself
with the people that want to control
abortion it's really--it's well I think
in our politics today it's the
authoritarian you like is not an
authoritarian a still think that the
Thorat arianism is good in some respects
and so unfortunately you are gonna fall
on weird sides of the issues there as
they're currently you know presented
yeah so let's just knock down a couple
other controversial topics then um so
drug war I'm gonna assume you are
completely against a drug war are you
are you absolutely for legalization of
everything completely legalize it and
let's just see what happens yeah is that
yeah that's it yeah I mean I think I
think there was a time when when these
kinds of drugs that were probably
thinking about as as you illicit were
legal and were you could buy them
over-the-counter and there wasn't an
epidemic that I know of you know of
opiate abuse and cocaine addiction and
heroin so it wasn't a systemic problem
yeah and even beyond that you you didn't
create powerful cartels that have yeah
you know that can actually determine the
way countries are governed yeah and that
were that were pretty much animated by
an ethics of violence you know and and
you didn't subject people who wanted to
procure these things to violence which
they are now and and because that's when
you make something you make a value that
people want and have the ability to
purchase a black market I
you're just subjecting them to an
element that is far more dangerous and
those people in this law enforcement
part of the of the world that you know
goes after drug folks at they they could
be used in far more efficient ways to
keep us safe
then putting people in jail and ruining
their lives for for just purchasing
something that's outlawed right and
often they're addicts which is basically
a disease I think it's classified as a
disease so you're punishing them I mean
you're and then you're wasting state
resources I mean it's it's coupled with
with a lot of stuff so when would it be
right to use state power is there any in
so if we were attacked let's just say
Canada starts lobbing missiles from
Toronto into Detroit yeah it would be
appropriate to retaliate it would be
appropriate and so we retaliate to the
extent that you end the threat
permanently not contain it not
marginalize it and keep it somehow
thriving but eliminate it permanently
because the the goal of retaliatory
forces to protect the innocent so is
this the irony when when I hear all my
progressive friends that want us out of
these wars and yet they're also for
higher taxes and yet it's our tax money
that's [ __ ] all this stuff wouldn't
you it always seems so obvious to me you
would want to starve the government of
the money so that every time they want
to build a new drone to send to
Afghanistan well maybe there's always
money for war I suppose but you would
want less government money so that they
couldn't do all these crazy adventures
right well I think the overwhelming
majority of the money that people are
the taxes are going to is the
maintenance of the welfare state the
regulatory state and a fraction of it
goes to to these to our war machine it's
hard to tell where it goes right they're
like you're all that and they show us
charts and I'm always like but there's
always money for war you know like it
just is always there and that's
unfortunate because yeah I think that
you know there is a there is and of
course it was a huge debate of course in
the founding of our country whether or
not a standing army was an appropriate
thing for it for a free country to have
in its wings but I do think it's a probe
thing given our sort of global
interconnectedness but not to create
Wars of democratization and and to
attempt to change cultures but simply to
protect American lives and property and
businesses here and overseas that's it
yeah so if you became president tomorrow
knowing that we have these crazy
situations I mean Iraq actually right
now is pretty much worse than it's been
at any point in the last 20 years we're
still at war in Afghanistan I just read
that as of two weeks ago Obama's the
longest president in war ever you know
so if you or whoever the American
capitalist presidential nominee would be
how do you just end that stuff just like
I mean do you literally just the day
you're in office you just rip up a lot
of treaties and you just get the hell
out of there is that is that doable is
that logical does that create a whole
other series of problems not to sound
like a pragmatist but you know one would
have to actually get in there you know
roll up their sleeves and see what the
extent of the damage is nothing but
certainly having a a principled foreign
policy would be a start I don't think
America's had a principled foreign
policy for decades decades in Vegas it's
certainly not in my lifetime I've been
here 51 years this rock so I mean having
a principled foreign policy means
understanding that the the the purpose
of government is to protect individuals
and from criminals and from from force
and to pursue America's interests period
it would be a principle I think America
has indulged itself and sacrificial Wars
of democratization and and literally
their their platform has been and I know
some folks who fought in the wars has
been literally to sacrifice American
lives for the sake of you know these
other people and cultures and and that
saccharine oils don't forget about the
oil well I don't know that we gained it
I mean that's even makes it more
appropriate to the altruist I think
I mean I think the people that said you
know we we went in there for oil as far
as I'm concerned that would have been
somewhat a healthy a healthy motivation
and that you know a tyrant was gonna try
to take over you know the oil and the
industrial world depends upon that the
environmentalists made it rather
impossible for us to kind of sustain our
own energy here through fossil fuel use
and it's it sort of made sense to keep
the oil flowing and the wheels of
Industry turning to a degree I mean I'm
really and I'm not saying that that made
you sound for war and again I'm saying
I'm saying that that would have been a
somewhat legitimate take on things
unfortunately it wasn't it was about
making a philosophical argument which I
always try to explain to people is
different than making rightfully right
it was about nation-building we don't
need to nation-build anybody we need to
just protect American citizens so so and
that that means always reacting never
initiating force against anyone is it
funny just to wrap up that even as you
were saying that that your subconscious
or whatever is back there is going don't
say something that somebody could
construe the other way which then goes
all the way around to where we started
which is this this beast of political
correctness and we've we've got to crush
it the hour is gone which I can't
believe yeah that was crazy we we have
done an hour so this has been a pleasure
and we will we will do this again yeah
and I hope some of these ideas I think
they're true I don't know they trickling
up or trickling down which would be the
better way they need to do both they
need they just all sorts of trickling
everywhere alright so I want to thank
mark Pellegrino for joining me you guys
can check out the American capitalist
society at American capitalist society